this video is proudly sponsored by
Squarespace stick around to learn more
about their service and a deal they're
making available through the channel
foreign
walking is for sure the most fundamental
human movement upon which our Evolution
pretty much revolves around and yet if
you look online on Fitness channels
you'll find there's very little mention
of walking so in this video we're going
to talk about why everyone should make
walking a priority in their lives how
you should walk optimally and we'll look
at the incredible healing power of
walking so come with me let's take a
walk
foreign
[Music]
Ty well we'll start with the obvious
basic stuff of course walking is a
fantastic way to burn calories and lose
weight in particular because it's
something anyone can do within reason
you can do it anywhere and with minimal
equipment when you walk you're burning a
relatively low number of calories but
you shouldn't think of this as the
workout the fact that you can walk in
between your training means that you're
getting this additional exercise this
additional calorie burning getting blood
flowing in between workouts and you
don't have to worry about recovery
because walking in many ways is the
recovery as we're going to see more in a
moment a lot of people who struggle to
lose weight even though they go to the
gym regularly don't realize that they're
so sedentary the rest of the day and if
only they walked more they could easily
be more active and burn more calories on
any given day
at the same time walking is also
fantastic for your brain many people
walk as a form of therapy it's been
shown to help with PTSD and countless
other issues as Andrew huberman talks
about when you walk a lot of information
comes into the eyes this is called optic
flow this places the brain into a more
relaxed state which is one of the
reasons it's so meditative
walking has also been used by many
people for idea generation you can use
it as a kind of inspiration walk and
many things throughout history from Carl
Jung to Nicola Tesla apparently used
this technique to come up with some of
their best ideas walking is a very
mindless activity allowing your mind to
wander and activate the default mode
Network brilliant if you want to just
Muse on a subject
this is why long multi-day hikes are
actually commonplace in many cultures
this works even better of course if you
are in an area that has natural beauty
which I know isn't something that
everybody can achieve but being around
nature and even just the color green can
help to put you into a more relaxed
state of mind it's also great for
creativity you're also at the same time
if you walk without an objective as
you're discovering new areas this is
fantastic because you're flooding the
brain with novel information which can
put you to a more plastic State and
actually walking around and wayfinding
is something that's very innate to The
Human Experience it's even possible that
we have a innate sense of direction a
Magneto reception an ability to sense
North there's some evidence to suggest
that this is a lost sense that we could
tap into I'm not saying that going for
walks is going to accomplish that but
it's just interesting to know how
fundamental it is to our daily lives and
our biology
at the same time though as well as
rejuvenating the Mind long walks are
extremely rejuvenating for the body this
is because walking can help to get blood
flowing around your body and it's a
brilliant form of active recovery if
you've had a big workout the previous
day going for a walk is one of the best
way to overcome Doms and if you're
struggling with an injury then gently
walking not through pain can be a great
recovery method
[Music]
but at the same time what I'm really
interested in is how walking can help
you to perfect your biomechanics so that
you're improving your not only your gait
but how this can also translate to other
aspects of your movement as I say
walking is such a fundamental aspect of
our daily activities that we evolved
kind of expecting to be walking on a
regular basis when you remove this it
leads to imbalances not only is it a big
issue that most of us no longer walk
half as much as we evolved to but at the
same time when we do Walk we're often
doing it incorrectly because we're
wearing thick heels in our shoes because
we're carrying a bag on one side not
necessarily an issue if you do it
occasionally but if that's the only way
you're walking when you commute to work
then this becomes a big issue
foreign
[Music]
movement in all planes so you should
have a lateral Bend from side to side
you should be rotating in the rotational
plane and you should have flexion and
extension in the sagittal plane so this
way you're getting movement throughout
your whole body and of course your arms
are swinging in a contralateral fashion
this is why it's a whole body exercise
and how you're able to get blood around
the entire body and this is also why
it's so important for improving your
general biomechanics that contralateral
arm swing it occurs as your heel strikes
the ground causing your glute to
contract on the opposite side in order
to stabilize the hips this then moves
across the thorasso lumbar fascia and
reaches the flat on the other side
triggering that contralateral swing of
course this contralateral movement is
present in so many aspects of human
movement whether you're throwing an
object or whether you're throwing a
punch you always have that connection
between the left hip and the right
shoulder and vice versa so walking is a
fantastic way to ensure that this is
working prop hopefully and to keep
yourself loose and limber and what you
need to remember is you take thousands
of steps a day at least you should be
you spend a short amount of time in the
gym but if you compare this to the
number of steps you take there's just no
contest you're rehearsing those
movements over and over again so what is
proper walking and biomechanics well
that really is opening up a whole can of
worms no one can quite agree but there
are some things that we can generally
assume based on our own structure so for
example some people say you should
actually be walking with a four foot
strike now I personally disagree with
this because if you look at the way the
heel interacts with the ground it
actually triggers a Cascade of reflexes
which help us to walk properly so for
example as the heel hits the ground this
actually causes the anterior tibialis to
activate and to slightly control that
plantar flexion and diversion in other
words it slows and controls the
downwards motion of the foot this
happens automatically walking is what
Nicola Bernstein would refer to as a
level B function this means it happens
entirely unconsciously it's largely
coordinated purely by reflexes which
occur as the fascia and tendons not only
store and return energy but also
communicate with one another send
signals through tension across the body
so all these things happen automatically
such that you can talk and think and
walk without having to pay attention to
where your feet are being placed and if
we look at how this works it can give us
some Clues as to how we should be
walking and moving our bodies so a
gentle heel strike even in barefoot
shoes is most likely preferable don't
slam the heel on the ground gently use
it to touch the ground and then roll the
foot and as you do the structures of the
feet will allow it to roll and then push
off and you should be pushing off of the
first and second toe and this is
actually why we don't have the kind of
opposable toe that you see in primates
because we need that stiffness to then
push off of the first and second toe
this is where wearing the wrong kind of
Footwear
basically meaning modern shoes can be an
issue because not only do you have that
padding on the heel which actually
dampens some of those signals coming
through but the closed narrow toe box
actually means you end up pushing off of
the wrong toes making you slightly less
stable making you slightly misaligned so
in general you should allow your body to
walk in a very natural way not muscling
through it because this is the other
feature of human walking it should be
highly energy efficient we've been
designed in such a way that our tendons
and our fascia do the heavy lifting by
returning energy and maintaining
momentum walking of course is highly
individual it's context sensitive but
these are some things that we can
generally assume from it you want to be
efficient in your movement so you're not
muscling your way through and you're
expending the minimum amount of energy
so that you can travel further with less
effort we see this for example in the
shoulders when you look at the
activation of the deltoids during
walking they are not what's driving that
swing in fact they actually are only
Contracting slightly to dampen the
movement and to aim didn't help to keep
the head nice and still you don't want
to overthink walking though and what
works for you is going to be different
from what works for somebody else the
point is to allow a natural and loose
feeling walk that isn't too effortful as
you do this and as you allow that
natural swing it's going to just help
loosen you up and like I say it's going
to reinforce that natural contralateral
movement pattern that then should
translate to other aspects of your
performance if you want to learn more
about this then I highly recommend
reading the books of Tom Myers as well
as James Earls who wrote born to walk
they're going to far more depth
discussing the role of the fascia the
spring load system and how the body
returns energy and basically walks in a
highly efficient way
walking off the beaten path is a really
good idea because that's far more
information Rich you have to adapt to
the Contours of the ground and look
where you're placing your feet over here
it's been pretty treacherous actually
with the frost and all these different
Hills and things for training
[Laughter]
experiment with walking faster whether
you're striding or strolling walking
slower even stalking through the woods
there's so many different ways to walk
and like I say I think this is just an
overlooked aspect of Fitness for many
people who kind of want to run before
they can walk let's see so this is
something I'm going to be returning to a
lot in future let me know in the
comments Down Below guys if you walk
regularly whether you do it for your
general fitness or whether you do it for
pleasure and if you are interested in
forms of training that talk about
many things that go outside the norm and
combine them into a single program then
you might like my ebook and training
program super functional training 2.0
the protein performance system comes
with over two hours of video tutorials
as well as an 80 plus page ebook you
might also be interested in my new print
book adaptive training which talks a lot
about this sort of thing about how the
way we move regularly throughout the day
is actually one of the biggest
determining factors in the way we move
in our Fitness in general a huge thank
you to grant for filming this one check
out his channel in the description down
below thanks to Squarespace for
sponsoring this video of course thanks
to you guys
and bye for now
[Music]
speaking of things that everyone can
benefit from I genuinely believe that
building a website can help anyone
whether it's to earn money to share a
passion or to organize an event or
something else thanks to today's sponsor
Squarespace creating a website really
couldn't be easier thanks to a huge
number of modern and highly customizable
templates you can build the foundation
of your website in minutes from anywhere
from there there are a huge variety of
powerful features that Empower you to
grow as far as your business needs it's
why Squarespace Powers many of the
biggest brands on the web you'll be able
to build your community and generate
Revenue with members only gated content
manage that Community with useful tools
or build it further with the fully
integrated commenting system with
threaded comments replies and likes
creating content is simple too thanks to
powerful blogging tools that include
formatting categorizing posts scheduling
and more you can even connect to your
social media so that posts are shared
automatically through your site those
looking to build their business further
can use the extensive e-commerce
capabilities to sell products and if you
need more you can add even more features
to Squarespace itself with a host of
third-party plugins including Inventory
management marketing streamlined
bookkeeping sales tax reconciliation
global Shipping and more more go to
squarespace.com to find out more and
when you're ready to get started go to
squarespace.com forward slash bioneer to
get 10 off the purchase of your first
website or domain
for anyone interested in starting a
website I truly believe that Squarespace
is one of the easiest ways to get
started so thanks once again to
Squarespace and a huge thank you to you
guys
bye for now